PETER S. MAGNUSSON: So of
course, we miserably failed
this morning to make sure that
the blimp looked like this,
from which the jumping
was done.
But we'll see what
we do next I/O.
All right, good afternoon,
everybody.
Thank you for joining us for
this App Engine overview.
It's a real treat to be here.
We have some fun news
to share with you.
So for those of you out there
on your Livestream, don't
touch that dial.
And for everybody, and in
particular those on
Livestream, here's a link for
the Google Moderator for
getting questions.
And our suggested hash is
#io12 and #appengine.
So we'll be reminding you of
this link for questions
throughout.
And we'll try to stay on
schedule as best as possible
to give room for
Q&A at the end.
So if by any chance you have no
idea what Google App Engine
is, this is what
we strive for.
We strive for development
platform in the clouds that
makes it easy to write
applications, simple to scale
them to a global audience,
and trivial to manage
running them over time.
The genesis for App Engine was
the internal development
stacks at Google, and a desire
by the founding team to
package them into a form that
lots of developers the world
over can use.
Since we launched in 2008, we
stayed true to this philosophy
and success has followed.
Adoption of App Engine has been
remarkably strong despite
a few limitations.
App Engine launched
with [INAUDIBLE]
surprisingly short list of
features, with a different
approach to writing modern
cloud applications.
But it was truly a child of
the new era of computing,
creating an opinionated
framework with large benefits
to early adapters.
Since the launch, we've been
hard at work in fleshing out
the platform, continuing our
quest for the ultimate cloud
platform service.
Over time, as we continue to
ramp our investments in cloud
computing, we continue to build
out our cloud products.
In addition App Engine, and also
over the last year and a
half, announcing products like
BigQuery, Google Storage for
developers, and Google
Cloud SQL.
In fact, traction has been
quite remarkable.
So I have a couple
of fun numbers to
share with you today.
If we look at the month in the
life of App Engine, we see
over one million hosted
applications.
So we recently passed
one million.
Not all of them were written by
everybody in the room here,
but thank you, developers,
for using App
Engine to develop apps.
This is pretty awesome.
Got to get you guys
going, here.
Yeah, I'm not diving for a
blimp, but this is still
pretty cool stuff.
The main storage system by
many of these Apps is our
multi-data center High
Replication Datastore.
And as far as we can tell, it's
the world's largest third
party NoSQL system.
In a given month, it processes
over two trillion operations.
Besides brand names
and [INAUDIBLE]
[? startups, ?]
App Engine powers hundreds of
thousands of applications that
you've never heard of.
In fact, we recently estimated
the overall reach of App
Engine applications.
And it's pretty breathtaking.
By our math, of all the internet
active addresses that
are active in any given week--
so of all the internet IP
addresses that we see being
active in a week--
over half of them touch App
Engine in any given week.
We can't track how many users
that corresponds to,
obviously, because there's
hundreds of thousands of
applications doing different.
But it's a pretty sizable
footprint.
Obviously, we're curious
about what's
behind these usage numbers.
So we look for patterns of
usage to guide us to what
features to prioritize.
With over a million
applications, the simplest
answer to the question of what
runs on App Engine is
everything.
But that's not really
very interesting.
We have seen some pretty
interesting broad patterns.
And they are quite
illuminating.
And in some ways, in hindsight,
they're fairly obvious.
I'm going to mention a couple
of areas of particular App
Engine traction.
The first one is sometimes
referred to
as Enterprise Edge.
So that's applications developed
by traditional
enterprises, but where the
target is mostly external to
the company.
It can be to reach tens of
thousands of partners, or
millions of customers.
The second is a fairly obvious
area, that of high tech
startups, which I suspect is a
big representation of Google
I/O participants, in particular
ones that are
social or mobile dimensions.
There's quite a number of
successful smartphone and
tablet applications that had
parts or whole of their
back-end infrastructure
running on App Engine.
The third one is
not so obvious.
And that's productivity
software.
I'm gonna talk about that
a little more later.
But first, I would like to
invite on stage Robert Fea
from a company that is
a household name.
[RIMSHOT SOUND]
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT FEA: Thank you, Peter.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Robert Fea.
I'm part of the Lowes.com
IT solutions team.
I'm going to take the next
several minutes to talk about
how we're using App Engine to
provide a better online
experience for our MyLowes
customers.
So of those of you who
aren't familiar with
MyLowes, what is MyLowes?
It's an initiative that we
launched last year to allow
Lowe's customers to
manage everything
about their homes online.
So they can manage and track
their purchase history, as
well as manage useful
characteristics about their
home, such as measuring out
their room dimensions, or
recording how much it costs
to mulch their yard.
And as part of our mantra to
never stop improving, we're
going to be introducing a new
file upload service using
Google App Engine that will
allow users to upload digital
assets into their MyLowes
accounts.
So we're going to walk through
a quick demonstration of how
that works.
As my colleague here is setting
up, let me just walk
you through a quick use case
how this might be useful.
So say you were remodeling
a kitchen.
And as part of that remodeling
you need to buy a new
refrigerator.
You saw a new Samsung
refrigerator that you really
liked at Lowes.com and
decided to buy it.
And for some reason or another,
you've had bad
experiences in the past
with refrigerators.
So you decided to buy the
warranty along with it.
Now, a lot of times with
warranty purchases, you'll
need to have the original
purchase receipt, as well as
the warranty receipt in order
to have any kind of service
done on a product.
And if you have trouble tracking
receipts, like
myself, this new feature
will definitely take
the pain out of it.
So as you can see here, my
colleague logged into his
Lowe's account.
He's going to go into
his home profile.
And from your home profile, you
can see you can enter in
all sorts of different
information about their homes.
But for this demonstration,
we're going to look at the
Photos tab, and the
Documents tab.
So you can see here, you
have the ability
now to upload pictures.
So say you wanted to upload a
picture of the fridge that you
just bought.
Now, keep in mind, all this
upload feature is being done
through the App Engine.
So you took a picture of
your fridge when you
first bought it.
And now it shows up on
your MyLowes account.
If you click on the
fridge itself, you
can make useful notes.
And you can zoom, also, in
and out in the picture.
OK, you can also have the
ability to upload--
in our scenario--
the warranty information.
So if we go to the
Documents tab--
So say I have the warranty
saved on my computer.
I just wanted to upload it to
my account and forget about
it, until I need it.
This is a pretty big file.
So we're giving users up to 200
megabytes of storage space
with file sizes ranging
up to 20 megabytes.
So now you have the
document uploaded.
If you need to ever refer
to it again, you can
simply click the link.
And it should show up.
Download, right there.
And there's our warranty
information.
So like I said, what are we
really using App Engine for?
Well, App Engine provides us a
useful set of RESTful APIs
that we can use to upload files
directly into cloud storage.
What else does it provide?
We're using the concept of
service accounts, so MyLowes
customers only need to sign in
once to access any information
in their cloud storage.
And I don't know if you were
paying attention, but we also
leveraged the App Engine API
image generation features.
So any time a user uploads
pictures into their MyLowes
accounts, we generate them.
They also have different
sizes that we use
throughout the site.
And we also do some Mime-Type
checking.
So we prevent users from
uploading harmful files into
their accounts.
Why did we decide to
go with cloud and
App Engine in general?
Well, as you may or may
not know, Lowe's is
not a software company.
So in order to make this kind
of feature work in our own
environment, we were looking
at potentially millions of
dollars in upfront hardware
investment.
Whereas, if we use App Engine,
we're looking, worst-case
scenario, hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
And because this is a new
feature, if it does take off,
we know that App Engine can
handle however many requests
users throw at it, and scale
without a problem.
That's pretty much it for my
part of the presentation.
I'm going to hand it
now back to Peter.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Software
updates are
available for your computer.
Thank you, Firefox.
OK.
Think we'll skip through on
the upgrade [INAUDIBLE].
The cloud is interrupting
my cloud talk.
Did I need to get--
there we go.
All right.
All right, thank you
very much, Robert.
So it's actually not a joke
that Robert looked at me.
I actually am remodeling my
kitchen at this very day.
I actually got a text for my
girlfriend on the fridge that
got delivered today.
So I was going to put in a joke
here about software, and
getting the kitchen sink,
because we actually
bought it at Lowe's.
But I'm going to
spare you guys.
The use case of Lowe's is a very
interesting one because
it leverages the tight
integration between Google
Cloud, Google Cloud Storage,
and Google App Engine.
So there's a lot of use cases--
in particular, in
Enterprise Edge-- that really
are storage-related problems,
that you need business logic
and processing and identity
and authentication, and so
forth, around storage issues.
And we already have quite a
good set of integration
features, and expect to see a
lot more because we think this
is a really important use case,
of basically building
logic on top of storage.
And it's also, of course,
a very good use case for
Platform-as-a-Service
in general.
Because even though I'm sure
MyLowes is going to have 10
million customers using this,
the adoption rates are always
going to be difficult
to predict.
So the usage patterns
are going to be
difficult to predict.
And they don't really have to
commit to any particular CAPEX
spending for this.
So if you remember my slide from
just before Robert joined
me, the second area of usage
that we found particular
traction for App Engine is in
startups, in particular, with
social or mobile direction.
And a most excellent example
is my next guest speaker.
Welcome on stage, Elliot.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIOT KROO: So Hi.
I'm Elliot Kroo, Founder and
Engineering Director at
Getaround, where we're
disrupting the transportation
industry by enabling people
to share their
cars with others nearby.
So Peter ask me here to talk a
little bit about Getaround,
and how we've grown
with App Engine.
I'm going to tell you a little
bit about Getaround, and then
how we've grown with App
Engine as a platform.
So right now, there are a
billion cars in the world.
Each car sits idle about 92%
of every single day.
They're literally
assets sitting
unused all of the time.
Getaround is here to
solve that problem.
Car owners make money from
an idle car that
they're renting out.
And car renters can get a
car when they need it.
This changes the transportation
game,
fundamentally, from ownership
to access.
Getaround is a marketplace.
So when you log in, you can
browse through full car
profiles that owners have
built for their car.
When you find cars that you
want, you can send out a
request to that owner
asking them to share
their car with you.
The owner can approve or deny.
If they choose to approve it,
they can send a digital key to
you to get into the car without
having to meet the
owner and exchange the key.
So Getaround started as a
university project, and made
its debut at a hackathon in
2009, about a year after App
Engine launched.
In two days and about four hours
of sleep, we built a
mobile app and a back-end
infrastructure to connect
owners and renters, and then
call out to a piece of
hardware connected to the
door locks of the car
that's being rented.
This is actually one of App
Engine's greatest strengths.
The ability to go in and take
an idea all the way to
execution, and launch a
production web application in
hours or minutes is something
that App Engine has been
really good at since day one.
There's no reconfiguration
required.
Google handles all
the boring stuff.
And we can focus on execution.
In 2011, everything seemingly
fell into place for us at
TechCrunch Disrupt.
So TechCrunch Disrupt is a major
startup competition.
It's a pretty big opportunity
for us.
In our case, we actually went
on to win both the main
VC-judged award, and the
audience choice award.
We were actually double-digit
percentage of all the Twitter
traffic during the main event.
So that led to massive
publicity.
A 30x increase in traffic
over that one
and a half hour period.
And best of all for me, the huge
opportunity for downtime
of our service right when
we needed it most.
Ultimately, it is me who's
responsible for keeping the
website up.
And right then, I was busy
getting drenched in champagne.
So you can guess how fast
I was paged with
our site going down.
It was literally never.
App Engine was great.
It over-provisioned
defensively.
And our latency during this time
of huge traffic went down
rather than up.
So App Engine has actually
been pretty cool.
In the last year, we've matured
as an organization,
both on the engineering side
and as a business.
And we've grown a lot.
Right now, we actually have an
inventory of thousands of
cars, ranging from Nissan LEAFs
to Tesla Roadsters.
And actually, we don't just have
one Tesla Roadster, we
now have seven listed on
the site that you can
rent out at any point.
And as we've matured, App Engine
has grown as well.
In 2009, App Engine was really
good to start on.
On the other hand,
it had a lot of
things that were missing.
It had no SLA.
It was missing the reliability
of the High Replication
Datastore when we
first started.
You couldn't even process
requests for
longer than 30 seconds.
There was just no
way to do that.
Over the last several years,
the App Engine team, one by
one, has been solving every
single one of these
limitations.
So now, with Python 2.7 support,
we can use a wide
variety of external libraries
on Python.
We use a MapReduce pipeline now
to power all of our weekly
analytics and report generation
over our now
massive data site that
we deal with.
And recently, we've been able to
move Search, which was our
last major component running
outside of App Engine, or in
our infrastructure from an
external third party index
server, to our own custom
in-memory time series
database, sitting on back-ends
right next to our front-end
instances in the same
data centers.
So just fairly recently,
actually-- it's pretty
exciting-- we're now able to run
our entire product, from
end to end, from the web app
and our mobile applications
infrastructure, to being able
to call out to our hardware
that we've built, without
compromise.
The whole system is now
running on App Engine.
This last 2 and 1/2 years
has seen a remarkable
transformation.
We've seen a remarkable
transformation in the way App
Engine has run.
It started as a young platform,
great for launching
new products, to a mature and
robust platform that we're
proud to run all of our
infrastructure on top of.
And we've grown as well, from
a hackathon project to a
successful business
with customers who
love what we're doing.
We're now 40 people strong
and growing.
So if you're passionate about
engineering and changing the
world, we're looking for
more people to join us.
So thanks so much, Peter.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Thank
you very much, Elliot.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, thank
you very much.
So I was tempted to insert a
joke about engines here.
But I will resist
that as well.
So what we've seen are two great
examples of successful
App Engine used.
The first time was Enterprise,
customer-facing application.
And the second one was a mobile
startup created in the
intensity of hackathons, and
then growing smoothly to be a
successful company.
And that's extremely exciting.
The third area that I wanted to
highlight today is a little
subtle, which is enterprise
productivity.
We have customers developing
hundreds of internal
applications on a per-company
basis on App Engine.
And in some cases--
including Google ourselves--
thousands of applications.
It turns out that much of the
work that we've spent to make
App Engine applications very
simple to own and manage--
we strive to make it trivial
to be actually running it--
in effect, translates into a
very low product lifecycle
management cost.
And this is very attractive to
companies that want to be able
to build and run lots
of applications.
So our next speaker is Mani,
who is from OrangeScape--
come up on stage-- who will
tell us a little bit about
their workflow technology.
[APPLAUSE]
MANI DORAISAMY: Thanks, Peter.
So my name is Mani Doraisamy.
I'm the co-founder and
CTO of OrangeScape.
I'm here to talk about
a new workflow
product called KISSFLOW.
Now, what's this new product?
Let's step back a little bit and
understand why KISSFLOW.
Now, most of us in this
room already use
Google Apps, right?
It's not just us.
Four million businesses are
already using Google Apps.
So Google Apps is collaboration
at its best.
If you look at Mail, Docs,
Calendars, all of them allows
you to do collaboration
on cloud very easy.
You can even put together
very simple data capture
applications on top of Google
Apps and spreadsheets,
especially the spreadsheets and
[INAUDIBLE] part of it.
But beyond that, when the users
want to implement a
slightly more sophisticated
enterprise application, let's
say a workflow application
like a recruitment
application, or for example,
a travel reimbursement
application, then we expect
them to be superheroes.
We want them to learn Python,
Java, understand the data
store concepts like BigTable on
top of Google App Engine.
Now, we thought, how will it
be if you can leverage the
power of Google App Engine and
make the workflow product as
simple as using Google Apps?
That's basically this
new product.
Today, we're excited to announce
the availability of
KISSFLOW, a simple and smart
way of building workflow
applications for Google Apps.
It's the first workflow product
exclusively for Google Apps.
And it leverages the full power
of Google Cloud, which
means it runs on top of Google
App Engine and Cloud SQL.
And it integrates with Google
Docs, and also Google Contacts
for collaborating.
And all of them come within
your workflow.
That's the beauty of it.
Let's take a quick look at how
workflow can be built on top
of KISSFLOW.
OK, so I think we are up on the
screen, on both the screens.
So this is how the workflow
looks like, building process
looks like.
So let's say, for example,
this company, Dark Knight
Enterprises, wants to clean up
their travel claim workflow.
It asks for Bruce Wayne, who's
the head of the department, to
create a workflow for automating
this process.
So KISSFLOW gives you a very
simple, five-step process to
create a wizard.
First, you start off with
naming the process.
And then you go into creating
the fields in the process.
Like, for example, in the case
of a travel claim form, you
have the purpose of travel,
which is what you capture to
claim the amount.
And then you have
the description.
And you also have fields, like
for example, amount, the date
on which the amount was
spent, and so on.
Once we complete creating this
form, for example, you can add
amount, which is basically
a number field.
And I can also make this
a required field.
And you can save this field and
that completes how expense
claim forms will look like.
So once I complete that, I can
go and define a process, a
workflow process.
A workflow process for a
travel claim would be,
typically, a two-step
approval process.
Like, for example, first, you
might want to send it to the
department head for approval.
So let's add Department Head
approval, which we will assign
it to two users.
One is, obviously, Bruce
Wayne himself.
And then we will assign
it to another user.
Like, for example, in this case,
we will assign it first
to Harvey Dent.
And then we will assign
it to Bruce Wayne.
So you can see that we are not
trying to integrate anything
with Google Apps.
All of the users get
synchronized directly from
Google Apps into KISSFLOW.
Similarly, we will add the
second step, which is for
finance approval, because
finance team would want to do
the approval themselves.
So in this case, we will assign
this to a Google group.
So anybody in this group can
approve this request.
Again, you can see you can
centrally manage all the user
management and group management
without having to
define roles, and manage
all of those things.
So once I am done with the
process creation and the form
creation, I can publish
this process.
And this is how it
looks [INAUDIBLE]
in the run time.
So you have a very similar
Gmail-like look and feel.
And I can initiate the
request where I can
see the expense claim.
And I can initiate the expense
claim request.
So this is exactly how you
saw in the Form Design
[INAUDIBLE].
So I can enter the
process purpose.
For example, I have broken my
car, and then I can specify
its official expense.
I don't know how many people
will claim breaking a car into
an official expense.
We'll put some amount
as 4,000.
And I can also attach a document
directly from here.
For example, I can attach a
travel document, so that the
next set of approvals
can look at this
document and do the approval.
So once we are done, I
can submit this item.
So this item, from the
initiator, will move
into the next step.
In this case, we defined
Department Head approval as
the next step.
So I can go into Approval
Request.
And then I can see the progress
of my entire process.
For example, I have initiated
from Bruce Wayne.
And it's waiting for department
approval.
So Bruce and Harvey are the
people who can approve it.
So I can click on Approve.
So if I click on Approve, it
goes into the next stage.
This way, I have completed my
automation of the process.
And I can also track to the
progress of the process,
without having to do
any coding at all.
That's the purpose
of this product.
Now, it's not just about
tracking of the workflow.
You can also do reporting
on top of this workflow.
For example, if I go to a
reporting tab, I can look at
the items as to how these
things can be
filtered and reported.
So with that, let me go into
the summary of KISSFLOW.
KISSFLOW is a very simple and
smart way of building
workflows, no technology
knowledge required.
But it also seamlessly
integrates with Google Apps.
So you get all of the
goodies of Google
Docs, Mail, and Contacts.
But it leverages the
power of Google App
Engine and Cloud SQL.
So when you log in, you have
a separate Google database,
which is a Cloud SQL
allocated to you.
So you don't have a problem
of sharing.
It's standardized for all of the
enterprises, because most
of the enterprise use RDBMS.
So you get the power of Google
Cloud, as well as the
power of Cloud SQL.
So thanks for your time.
We are at Sandbox.
You can always visit us for
more demo because there is
quite cool stuff that's
around there.
And you can also try it out
at www.kissflow.com.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: I
need the clicker.
Thank you.
All right, thank
you very much.
And now the moment you've
all been waiting for.
We have a couple of improvements
to announce to
App Engine today.
So for that I'd like to
welcome on stage, Greg
D'Alesandre, the lead product
manager of Google App Engine.
Take it away, Greg.
Let's hear it.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Thank
you, Peter.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG D'ALESANDRE: So I know
we're running out of time.
So I'll try to get through
this quickly.
We've made a lot of improvements
to App Engine.
But I wanted to give you a
little bit of insight of
what's been going on with App
Engine since we came out of
preview in November
of last year.
We've continued our rapid pace
of innovation, continuing to
produce approximately one
release per month, including
such things as Python 7, Backup
and Restore, traffic
splitting threads, but a number
of improvements that
have happened over the course
of the last six months.
Today, though, we want
to talk about 1.7.0.
In 1.7.0, we have a number of
things coming into general
availability that people have
been requesting for, in some
cases, a very long time, as well
as some new surprises.
The first I'd like to talk
about is SSL for custom
domains is finally
going into GAE.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG D'ALESANDRE: There
are two flavors of it.
There is SNI, which supports
the majority of browsers.
But for some people, some of
their applications, it doesn't
support it.
So we also support
a VIP option.
SNI's a little cheaper.
Because VIPs, we actually need
to give you a dedicated IP
address, which, if you can
believe it, is expensive.
Single VIPs and SNI can actually
support multiple
applications by use of wildcard
or multi-domain
certificates.
All right, I'm going to start
talking fast to make sure we
get all the information
out there.
Cloud SQL, again, one of the
most requested features for
App Engine, today is going
into open sign up.
So now, anyone can
use Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL's a MySQL database in
the cloud, easy management,
so zero admin configuration,
synchronous, geo-replication.
It's already being very heavily
used by a lot of our
customers, including
OrangeScape, as you just saw.
And there is zero admin from
configurations backup.
Next, the Search API.
So we released our experimental
Search API
approximately a month ago.
I just wanted to highlight that
experimental Search API
is out there.
And as of 1.7.0, we've actually
added in GeoPoint support.
So you can make location-aware
searches.
This is one of the biggest
requests we had for Search.
And we just added it
in this release.
The Search API itself allows
for the indexes are
schemaless, giving you
scalability and flexibility in
your search indexes.
You can do things like
custom scoring and
snippets, et cetera.
Next, Google App Engine
European Data Centers.
So Google App Engine is
now being hosted--
[APPLAUSE]
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Google App
Engine is now being hosted out
of both the US and the
European Union.
So this is for customers who
are interested in running
their applications out of the
European Union, either for
performance reasons, for their
customers in other parts of
the world, or for compliance
reasons.
When you run out of the EU, your
application instances run
out of the EU.
But all of your end-user
data is stored at rest
in the EU as well.
This is launching today for
premiere customers.
Simultaneously, we also have
local contracts available for
Premier customers in Europe, as
well as local currencies,
such as British pounds, euros,
yen, and Australian dollars.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG D'ALESANDRE: [LAUGH]
There's some international
people out there that are very
excited about that.
Next, PageSpeed Service
for App Engine.
Let me show you a little
bit of a demo on this.
This is actually the blog for an
App Engine customer, Pulse.
What you will see here is
the before and after.
So you'll notice--
if I can pause it-- after about
1.8 seconds, everything
had rendered on their
blog, initially,
of what they needed.
And then full rendering was
done in 8.2 seconds, as
opposed to the 11 seconds
that it used to take.
What PageSpeed Service does,
it's a service we launched a
little while ago at
Google in general.
But we've now made it available
to App Engine that
you can enable with
a single click.
It automatically optimizes
performance, such as image
optimization, deferring
JavaScript loading, inlining
CSS in JavaScript, rewriting
cache headers.
It does all of the stuff you
need to do to increase
performance.
And let me move on from that,
because who knows what's going
to be on that YouTube?
Yeah, there we go.
The next thing I wanted to talk
about was Cloud Endpoints.
This is the last thing
I wanted to bring up.
But it's, frankly, one of the
things I'm most excited about.
It's really in the spirit
of App Engine.
What we brought you with Cloud
Endpoints is a really easy way
to make mobile backends, and
backends for web-based
applications using App Engine.
So it exposes a REST API
for Android iOS and web
applications.
There's a JavaScript client
library, strongly typed client
libraries in Java and
Objective-C, as well as we
take care of all that
OOF2 that no one
wants to learn about.
The whole goal is really to
make it so that if you're
building a mobile application
and you want a backend on your
mobile application, it's really
easy to use App Engine
to get that done without
having to learn all the
details and do any of
the heavy lifting.
In many ways, it's the
promise we've always
wanted with App Engine.
All right, that's 1.7.0
in a nutshell.
And I don't think I've ever
talked that fast before.
But that's 1.7.0
in a nutshell.
We wanted to save a little bit
of time for questions.
And I know there are probably
a couple out there.
So the last thing I want to
do, as we're answering
questions, is please come visit
our Partner Sandbox.
There's a number of customers
that are using App Engine and
Partner Sandbox.
You can talk to App Engine
developers in the Sandbox.
We also have crazy plushies
over there that you can
probably sweet talk your way
into, t-shirts, custom
chocolate bars, and gel skins.
It's a lot of swag this year.
So I think we have a
couple minutes, if
people have any questions.
I see someone getting up now.
Although, he might be leaving.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Do
we have a microphone?
GREG D'ALESANDRE: There we go.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I had
a question--
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Start with
an audience question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about the control over
synchronization across
continents.
Do you have the ability to,
for example, block an App
Engine from being replicated
over to the EU?
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Is your
question, if you currently
have an App Engine in the US
and you want to move your
application over to the EU,
how do you do that?
AUDIENCE: Well, we want
to restrict it to
a particular continent.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: To both?
So as of today, the way it works
is you choose, when you
create your application, if you
want it in the EU, or if
you want it in the US.
So we don't currently have a way
that your application can
be shared across both places.
Although, you could build your
own structure for essentially
storing data and routing
traffic into
the appropriate location.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: And to be
clear, that's a feature.
So that's very intentional.
In fact, we had to do
engineering to not have data
going back and forth.
Because we want to be able
to-- for all European
customers--
to be clear that, unless they
say very specifically
otherwise, the application and
user data resides in the EU.
AUDIENCE: I'm a federal
government customer, which is
why I was asking.
Because if we wanted to create
App Engine applications for
Enterprise, we wanted to make
sure that it remains within
the continental US.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: I'm sorry,
I don't think I got that.
AUDIENCE: We wanted to make
sure that the application
remains in continental US.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Ah, yes.
Oh, yes, absolutely.
Sorry, that's the feature that
Peter was referring to.
We make it very clear, you
choose either US or the EU.
We don't automatically share
your application anywhere.
You're making an explicit choice
where you want to host
your application.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: So we have
some moderator questions.
So I'll read them.
First one, "Where do you think
GAE pricing is heading?
As developers leverage the
platforms more and more,
pricing certainly becomes one
of the main selling points."
And stay tuned.
We are working on some news on
that that did not make press
line for Google I/O. But
we're very aware of it.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Let's be
clear, good news on that.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Good news.
Yeah, let's be very clear
on that, yes.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: I was on
stage last year with some
other news.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So no, we're not
raising prices.
We're looking at various forms
and more control for
customers, and more options.
So it basically, to
allow as your
application becomes bigger--
what we found is that when
you're a startup, and you're
early, you're building small
applications, you're not very
sensitive to inefficiencies
of your design.
But as you scale up, App Engine
provides all these
wonderful ways of shooting
yourself in the foot because
it's very easy to use.
It's very easy to start using
a lot of resources.
So we find that larger
customers with larger
footprints need to have more
options to trade off between
features and capabilities
and price.
So stay tuned on that.
We hope to have updates on
that no later than Q3.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Should we take
another live question?
PETER S. MAGNUSSON:
Let's do two, one.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Oh, sure.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Because
this is all the Livestream
folks as well.
So second one is, "App Engine
just released OR queries in
the new SDK.
Are these true OR queries or do
multiple queries then merge
the results?
If so, how does the billing
work on these?"
So let's do an audience
question.
[LAUGHING]
GREG D'ALESANDRE: I tried,
man, I tried.
I'm looking down to the App
Engine team in the audience.
Actually, that's a detail
I don't know off
the top of my head.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Everyone is
looking at somebody else.
So let's do an audience
question.
We'll get back on this.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: As they're
texting the people who do know
the answer to that question.
AUDIENCE: So you're not going
to get away from answering
cost information that fast.
Actually, my question has to
do with how should large
companies deal with deployments
of App Engine
applications, in terms of cost,
because they're unknown.
Basically, there is the
App Premier, or
the App Engine premier.
There is a bunch of costs
associated with
anything you do.
And at the end of the day,
budgeting-wise, it's a nightmare.
How do you even know what this
application is going to cost?
And should you have done it in
house, versus send it out?
Are there any tools, for
example, if you use Django
inside to be able to instrument
these things, and
be able to at least get a
baseline, or an idea of what
this thing's going to cost?
GREG D'ALESANDRE: So in general,
the best way to
understand how much our
applications are going to cost
is by running it and
load-testing it to get an
understanding of whether it's
the number of users you have,
or the number of calls, or
whatever is the metric you're
looking to scale to understand
how many that you can handle
with an individual instance.
The way App Engine pricing works
is, either you're paying
for API call, which are very
set, or you're paying for
instances, which are a
combination of CPU and memory.
And it's how we've run
your application.
Because the instances of a code
you write, the only way
you can really know how many
instances you're going to need
are by load-testing it and
seeing how your application
does behave under load.
So the way to understand and
predict how much App Engine
will cost is by, essentially,
running your application
there, and testing it, and
seeing what it uses.
It's part of the reason we give
a free quota, so that
people can test applications out
there to see what it would
take to run.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON:
So I'd like to add
two things to that.
So we see these things in the
enterprise space falling down
in two broad areas.
One is the load-testing, where
we're looking at ways to make
it easier for you to build
load tests and cost
estimators, and so forth.
We're looking at those things.
And the other area is around of
control of costs, which as
your developer team-- especially
in Enterprise
case-- starts growing up,
you need to have--
you know, in App Engine, if you
create a premier account,
basically you have
very coarse-grain
controls in the budgets.
And you need to have more
fine-grain ones, so that some
arbitrary contractor that you
bring in doesn't change a set
of indexes.
And before you know it, you're
burning through 100K more a
month than was necessary
because it wasn't being
caught, and things like that.
So those are the two areas that
we're looking at, that
we're working on bringing
you things.
One is to make it simpler.
You can do it today, do
all the benchmarking
and measuring yourself.
But there are lots of things
we can do to make
that simpler for you.
And the other one is to provide
more fine-grain
controls around budgeting.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Want to
do another audience one?
Because I'm scared now of
the online questions.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Well,
any news on using
SSL with custom domain?
Yes, there is news.
It's now GAE.
I love answering the
easy questions.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Yes,
we now have it.
[INAUDIBLE] " Because of
limitation of Google App
Engine, many useful Python
libraries couldn't be used on
the Google App Engine
platform.
Is App Engine team planning some
way to solve the problem
to prevent developers keep
rebuilding the wheel?" Yes.
[LAUGHING]
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Question
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: I'm looking for a
CouchDB type replacement.
So regarding the Enterprise
Edge, I'm really interested in
the enterprise synchronization
across Europe and the US.
But I'd also be able to like
to synchronize into a
disconnected device when
it's disconnected.
So if there's a pilot flying
around in a 747, is carrying
an Android, when it lands
somewhere, I'd like to be able
to synchronize.
And of course, when it's up in
the air, you can't do that for
different reasons.
Same for precision
agriculture.
The same for, actually,
military logistics.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: All right,
so those are sort of two
different areas.
Synchronization between the EU
and the US, we are for now not
looking at any particular
features.
You need to code
that yourself.
And the reason for that
is very intentional.
It's that you own the legal,
and whatever consequences
there are of those algorithms.
So we don't want to be in a
situation where a corporation
in Europe, who is
jurisdictionally required to
keep end-user data locally
because of some setting in
some dialogue box somewhere
suddenly got synced over to US
Supreme Court jurisdiction.
So this is actually a feature
that we explicitly want to
make the developer problems, so
the developer can decide on
the policy.
So that Google can
just say, no, the
developer's decided for.
And it's the developer's
responsibility.
The other one is synchronization
between App
Engine and mobile devices.
Was that the other part of it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and really,
how would I synchronize
[INAUDIBLE] from App Engine to a
disconnected Android device?
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Right.
So for us, that's higher
up in the stack.
So there are lots of other cool
talks at Google I/O about
how to do mono-web
applications.
I would direct you to the talk
that Dan is doing on
Dart, and using it.
So we have various web stack
technology stuff going on to
make that simpler.
From the App Engine point
of view, that is
the application layer.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: And speaking
of talks, I would highlight,
check out all the sessions
around Cloud platform.
There's a session tomorrow
morning around Cloud Endpoints
to go into a lot more detail
about how to use them, and how
to build them.
I did mention I was
excited about it.
So I'm going to mention that
talk over and over again.
There's also a talk on Friday
about optimizing your App
Engine application.
So there's a number of talks
over the course of I/O around
using App Engine.
I think there's a Python 2.7
talk tomorrow as well.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Want to
take an audience question?
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Sure.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Oh, we're
going to alternate.
AUDIENCE: I run a data
center in Asia.
Do you have any plan?
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Do we have
plans for Asian data centers?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Was
that the question?
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: We have
nothing to announce today.
So one of the things I wanted
to emphasize is that App
Engine runs on many
data centers.
So we don't have a
single point of
failure on a data center.
So as opposed to some Cloud
products, we can't say we're
in a region just because there's
one data center there.
We have to have several.
And so we have to have a
pretty large footprint.
So we currently have sorted
that out in Europe.
And we've said before with HRD,
we copy, we make, we can
handle more than one data
center failure.
So we're running at a set of
data centers that are spread
apart over multiple countries.
And we've been doing US
for several years.
In Q4 last year, we went out of
preview and became a fully
supported commercial product.
And this year, we're
announcing Europe.
So you can extrapolate from
that curve on what we're
likely to be doing.
One thing we have said is that
Japan is App Engine's
second-largest customer,
which is awesome.
So Asia is very big.
So we'll take an online one
here. "Could you please
provide the roadmap to improve
the datastore backup and
restore functionalities, in
particular the restore by
namespace?" We are working
on this as well.
GREG D'ALESANDRE:
We are indeed.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Nothing
specific to announce today.
GREG D'ALESANDRE: And I didn't
mention it as part of 1.7.0.
But as part of 1.7.0, there
actually was an improvement to
backup and restore in order to
allow you to restore to a
different app ID after
you've done a backup.
That came out in 1.7.0.
I just gave the highlights.
But you should definitely
check out the
release notes for 1.7.0.
There's a ton of new
stuff in there.
But the specific question around
backup and restore for
namespace, we've definitely
heard before and we are
looking at.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: "Does App
Engine plan on integrating
with any version control
system such as GitHub,
Project, or Subversion?"
We have looked
at this in the past.
We've talked to some of these
players in the past.
We're probably going to have
a second look at that.
It's something that makes
a lot of sense.
So I think the short answer is,
yes, we plan on developing
integrations, or facilitating
for integrating with version
control systems.
We want to take [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Any plans
for support of
Node.js, or other languages?
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Yes,
more language supports.
Yes, we want to add more
languages to App Engine.
And we're working on it.
We have nothing more to
announce at this I/O,
unfortunately.
Another online. "App Engine
continues to be compared to
traditional relational
databases.
Do you see Google making
it even more easier for
developers to transition by
adding features to App Engine,
documentation, use cases,
et cetera?"
Yes, I think we're doing
quite a lot.
So the usability of the
datastore, of the Google NoSQL
solution, I think, over time has
been adding features and
reducing the restrictions that
are fundamental, that have
been viewed as being
fundamental
between SQL and NoSQL.
I think we're going to continue
down the path if we
take the 30,000-foot view of
cloud-based SQL system
becoming faster and more
scalable, while at same time,
cloud-based NoSQL systems slowly
start shedding the
historical limitations of what
sort of queries and processing
that you can officially
do against them.
And then, in the not too distant
future, I think,
actually, we're going to end
up having not much of a
difference between them.
So one of things that we're
trying to do with App Engine,
with the addition of Google
Cloud SQL, is not
just SQL, per se.
But it's to provide MySQL
interface that has a lot of
aspects that people are
very familiar with.
So we're trying to create an
environment in App Engine,
where if you want the very
scalable in terms of lots of
queries, of the types that
web applications do,
we can scale great.
Whereas, if you have this
account data, or internal
application data that requires
SQL reporting, or things like
that, you can put those
in Google Cloud SQL.
So I think what you can
anticipate us doing in Cloud
in general, is to continue
to improve datastore's
capabilities, and working on
reducing or minimizing the
restrictions that NoSQL have
historically done, while at
the same time improving the
integration with SQL.
But for a long time, I think
the best way of building
applications is to think about,
what data naturally
resides in memcache, what
naturally resides in a NoSQL
part, and what naturally resides
in the SQL part.
Want to take a--
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Yeah, let's
take a live question.
AUDIENCE: Every App Engine
developer in the enterprise
eventually has a conversation,
usually with boss of the boss
of the boss of his boss, where
the assistant executive vice
president says, but my
data is precious.
It's mine.
How can I trust that Google will
not take it, and do what
we're doing, but better?
So what is the answer?
What are the guarantees?
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Well, a couple
of the guarantees we
make are illegal ones.
If you read our terms of
service, it does say what we
can and can't do to the data.
I know that there are a lot of
people have asked a similar
question of, like, are you going
to take my data and put
it into a search index and make
search all that better?
First of all, I think we'd have
a hard time understanding
your data to try to put it
into a search index.
But secondly, contractually,
we can't.
We basically say that we can't
take your data and then
re-share it.
We essentially can use your
data for the purpose of
providing you your application,
not for
essentially anything we want.
But this is one of the
transitions that's going on in
the world right now, is as data
is moving into the cloud,
some people get anxious
about it.
And the best that we
can do is show that
we've never done that.
We've never implied we're
going to do that.
We've never hinted we're
And we have contracts saying
we can't do it.
Beyond that, other than me going
and talking to them and
saying, no, seriously,
seriously, we're
not going to do it.
You know, it's hard to make
more guarantees than that.
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Over the
last year, I've been on a
number of panels and discussions
around the world
where variations of this
topic comes up.
And I've been on stage in
various combinations with
pretty much all the other large
public cloud providers,
all the names you've
all heard of.
And there's a pretty strong
consensus in the industry--
of at least us vendors--
that we're seeing all of our
Enterprise customers adjusting
to the absolute opposite
point of view.
Which is that the enterprises
start trusting the public
cloud provider to manage their
data more than their own
capabilities of doing it,
simply because we
live and die by this.
I mean, Google fundamentally,
from the start, has had a huge
element of handling privacy
implications, legal
implications,
cross-jurisdictional issues
about all the data that's in
Gmail, all the data that's in
Docs, all the data that we're
crawling everywhere, all the
various challenges we've had
with things like Street View,
and so forth.
So Google's DNA, from the ground
up, is totally even
over-sensitized to
these issues.
So actually, one of the
reasons we've had--
maybe I even shouldn't say
this-- but one of the reasons
we've been challenged with
adding more languages to App
Engine, is precisely because of
internal security concerns.
So we have so many layers of
approvals and review and
audits and design commentary,
and so forth.
And it's very difficult
for us.
We can't just start building
shit and running it on our
data centers.
It's not allowed.
It's a public fact that Google
has over 300 full-time
engineers that all they
do is security.
So whenever you read about the
various security breaches that
happen to companies, you never
see it happening with the
large public cloud providers,
because that is
our bread and butter.
But that said, as anybody who
actually knows things about
security, there's no such thing
as the 100% guarantee.
But this pervades all
of our activities
and building services.
And one of things I would say
to your boss's boss's boss's
boss is that almost 50% of the
Fortune 100 companies' SEC
filings are now done
on web filings,
which runs on App Engine.
So I've been on numerous
conference calls with CIOs of
Fortune 100, and a couple of
CIOs from Fortune 10 companies
and walked them through
these issues.
And what tends to happen is
that there's push back.
And they don't quite
understand it.
Then they realize, OK, the
public cloud is, if anything,
safer than running
it yourself.
It's very, very difficult to
have high security yourself.
It's a little bit like
driving versus
flying commercial airlines.
You think that you're safer
because you're in control.
The reality is, that that
pilot's probably a better
educated flyer than you are.
Should we cut it right there?
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Yeah,
we could do one more.
[INAUDIBLE].
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: One more?
Let's look which one it
is before we do it.
"Logs of the App Engine are
close to impossible to use.
Are there plans to support
better search and browsing
capabilities?" Oh my god, yes!
GREG D'ALESANDRE:
Yes, exactly.
Absolutely, without question.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER S. MAGNUSSON: Actually,
when I joined Google, this was
one of the first things.
I think after six weeks I said,
can we please add better
logs processing systems?
So yes, we are working
on a lot of stuff.
And in fact, I think you're
going to see us leapfrog from
one extreme of having
a pretty--
yeah, I'm not going to use
derogatory words about our own
product-- but challenging
environment for managing and
searching and analyzing large
logs, to the other extreme,
where we plan to have the best
logs management support system
on the planet.
You should expect Google
BigQuery to be
a big part of that.
Thank you very much,
everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG D'ALESANDRE: Oh, yeah.
Code Lab, when's Code Lab?
There's a video of a Code Lab
showing how to get your App
Engine logs into BigQuery, to
do analytics on your logs.
That was a Code Lab that
happened earlier today.